in the latter half of the 2000s the Sam
Raimi Spider-Man trilogy by Columbia
Pictures and Sony is finally winding
down as the studio gets an uncertain
territory about the fourth film
Spider-Man's hit big in the world of
video games with multiple open world
hits in a row and the time has come for
another animated series to keep the
brand invigorated and Alive as we wait
to see what the next movie becomes so
cartoon vets Greg Weissman and Victor
cook were tasked by Sony to create a
serialized Spidey TV series to fill in
the gaps and breathe in some new life
for the character after his last cartoon
outings all kept him relatively the same
as a college age superhero believe it or
not putting him back in high school was
not an incredibly annoying decision at
that time he was in high school for
barely any of the movies hadn't been
there for decades in the comics and the
video games barely had time to show any
of his life at home so cook and Weissman
took Spidey back to his roots as a 16
year old high school superhero but the
plan for the series to span time through
his school career from Fall to summer
vacation each year until he's graduated
moving on to college they had a lot of
big multi-year plans for this series
that we'll talk about later and I felt
that was conducive to Stronger
storytelling because nothing felt like
it came out of left field the
foreshadowing was implanted for
everything that happened in the series
and it introduces characters long before
they become relevant
so when they do take the center stage
you're like oh yeah I've seen that guy
like three or four times before in the
background this show is a master class
in setup and payoff you can thank me
later dude
[Music]
[Laughter]
we all know now that these long-term
plans didn't exactly come to fruition as
the show was canceled after two seasons
due to the Disney and Marvel merger in
2009 and often the only conversations we
have about this show revolve around that
cancellation and how much we all wish it
would come back but you've got to be
realistic and come to terms with the
fact that this isn't really likely going
to happen instead of being the millionth
video encouraging a hashtag campaign to
bring it back let's just talk about what
the show did and didn't do that made it
so unique and appreciated for what it is
instead of lingering on what it
unfortunately could have been
and yeah what else is there to say
Spectacular Spider-Man is almost perfect
The Spectacular Spider-Man charts the
early years of this Show's take on
Spidey as he grows and matures through
his high school career as well as
develops complex relationships with a
massive cast of Side characters that are
all really strongly characterized every
person he comes in contact with is an
interesting and fleshed out character
that could have multiple episodes about
them too but of course no one
overshadows Peter Parker himself this is
a fantastic take on Spidey he's angsty
but not too angsty he's smart but not
too smart he's a nerd but not like a
socially inept loser he's also comic
accurate and that he can't walk two feet
without a girl falling in love with him
don't you just love my balls
hot sticky wet balls coming at you he's
flawed and makes genuine mistakes in the
show that can't be rationalized away and
he learns from those mistakes but he's
still a lovable character
of all the cartoons I'd say this is
definitely the richest and most complex
take on Peter that translates him pretty
much perfectly from the comics every
adaptation focuses on specific traits in
particular but this one is the most
well-rounded and complete translation I
can think of that spot on Parker writing
goes hand in hand with this
well-developed cast of Friends and
begrudging Ally Frenemies his home life
is so crucial because it sets him apart
from other Heroes subtle things like the
multi-episode arc beginning with him
being admonished by Aunt May for staying
out too late on a school night you're to
be home by 10 o'clock
it's my bedtime but Aunt May if you're
late you call and in the following
episodes having to call if he's up past
his curfew it's slow going but uh I'll
be home soon I hope so the weatherman
predicted rain
it's just somehow I doubt an umbrella
would help little things like that make
it feel more real like he's a real kid I
love that this show managed to
accurately show the evolution of enemies
to friends that Peter and Flash Thompson
have in a way that felt natural and not
forced or too quick if you're hanging up
on the she geek that proves you're still
a stuck up Egghead
a guy who can't even see when his
friends are trying to help
but so far as to adapt Harry Osborne's
battle with drug addiction while also
keeping it within the bounds of cartoon
content restrictions this is the only
thing to ever adapt that Arc it's crazy
like even semper couldn't finagle
something like that they just swapped
out the heroine with a fictional
performance-enhancing drug developed by
Oscorp that he uses to get better at
Sports and improve his grades I got
straight A's on my midterms I made the
varsity football team first string and I
have a date to tonight's fall formal
with one of the hottest version can't
you see I'm in a meeting this show was
written so well that they somehow
managed to have a whodunit with Green
Goblin and legitimately make you think
that Norman Osborne isn't the lead
suspect I mean you feel stupid when you
realize it is because like of course but
wow it's like that hobgoblin stuff but
good plus all the juicy girl problems
and love triangles are just great
somehow Liz Allen is best girl I don't
know how to reconcile that MJ is so
barely in this show but when she's there
she steals the show the side characters
are also perfectly handled Kenny Kong is
here but he doesn't contribute much
remember him he's Brian bennis's OC
that's the only kid at school who could
figure out Spider-Man's identity and he
also gets to date Kitty Pride whom
Bendis is obsessed with that guy's not
gonna be in the movies they're also a
lot of nice little indignities that
remind you that being Spider-Man isn't
all it's cracked up to be like Peter
entering an intense Chase sequence that
spans the entire city and then realizing
he forgot his shoes on a skyscraper and
now the Amazing Spider-Man is reduced to
sneaking around for his shoes or burning
his tongue on hot cocoa before a big
fight yeah it's still doing Pleasant
what
I burned my tongue okay not to mention
his costume being too vulnerable to the
elements in winter time and his
laborious process says to earn the funds
to get some long johns under that [ __ ]
one in the Sun not so much in the snow
these things are the things that make
Spider-Man down to earth and relatable
relatable doesn't mean he's a
self-insert devoid of Personality it
just means he deals with everyday
conflicts that feel like something your
average person would encounter and
struggle with Spider-Man isn't 100 just
me he's a very distinct character
however he and I have both stressed
about paying bills or have possibly torn
our pants in public being a normal
person isn't totally glamorous sometimes
it sucks and this show does a really
solid job of portraying that aspect of
the character without feeling like
they're going overboard and dumping on
him for the sake of it everything to
love about this series is very nuanced
everything is calibrated perfectly not
too much or too little of anything so
much of this shows Spider-Man and Peter
Parker activities are so deftly handled
but what's a hero without a villain a
brother to the charlatan but a major
factor of this show is its villains much
like a lot of early Batman stories that
focus on the transition from realistic
Gangland crimes to Freaks and costumes
this series uses spidey's introduction
to the city as a catalyst for the same
sort of evolution all of his more
down-to-earth villains like the burglars
and crime Lords are presented as having
been around for a long while before he
got his powers and you see that genre of
criminal being phased out in favor of
animal themed high-tech or super powered
goons that throw cars at each other even
the old style Crime Boss silvermane gets
a silly transforming battle suit to keep
up which is very reminiscent of that Arc
in the comics where he uses severed head
and a robot like RoboCop they use that
for Hammerhead the new games all
Spectacular Spider-Man storylines run in
three episode arcs in a way that makes
them feel like four to five issue arcs
in a comic run and these are all
centralized very heavily around things
he's learning at school and the
education and or development of Peter
Parker as Greg Weissman put it I find
that this show follows my personal rules
about the ideal way to adapt a
long-running comic Arc which is to use
what works and strengthen what doesn't
it's not a one-to-one adaptation of the
Lee ditko era or the bendison Bagley
books because barring Nostalgia goggles
both have completely different problems
now Peter isn't a weird Iran reading
edge Lord but he's also not dating his
adopted sister Gwen Stacy comic books
are bad I'm so sad every day for one
they did use the idea that Otto Octavius
was a disgruntled ex-oscorp employee who
went mad from being abused by his boss
all the time but they decided to set
this up as a framing device and
introduce a lot of spidey's enemies by
having them be Oscorp rejects
commissioned by the local Mafia to fight
Spider-Man here the idea works because
it's paced out well enough but this idea
would later irritate the [ __ ] out of me
in the movies and games by having oscore
be the top super villain Factory in the
world sometimes you just gotta have a
criminal fall into a super collider
that's fun too gotta be careful where
you fall and the show has its fair share
of villain origins like that too with
Electro Venom Craven and Mysterio being
completely unrelated to Norman Osborne's
Shenanigans they augment this more
modern approach to Spidey villains by
also including a lot of classic guys You
Don't See Much Anymore like the
enforcers the tinkerer and silvermane
naturally they do little things to fit
them in better into a more modern
setting but I think all of it works
making Montana from the enforcers become
shocker was kind of an interesting
choice I guess the reason that Oz Court
being a super villain Factory in this
show works is because like the criminals
are hiring them to do that instead of
them making Dr Octopus arms and vulture
wings and Rhino suits and all this
dangerous [ __ ] for like no reason at
least there was like politics happening
behind the scenes that explained why
they were building these crazy stupid
inventions really the only change this
show made to a classic villain that I
don't Vibe with was fusing Craven and
Puma into like one character he was cool
without being a silly tiger guy this was
too much we left the crazy furry
villains on counter Earth guys please
this is also the only Spider-Man
adaptation to not butcher the [ __ ] out
of George Stacy so that's cool he
totally knows he's Spider-Man is sick
maybe a man in a mask doesn't have
something to hide but something to
protect
wouldn't you agree
uh
yes sir normally I'd say that High
School Spidey is too early to introduce
Venom but this series gets it right by
developing that Arc over a while in the
first season and accomplishing two
things one Venom is still an alien and
two Eddie Brock has legitimate beef with
Peter Parker without also being
irredeemable somehow doing both of these
is very hard for a lot of adaptations
plus making Eddie around the same age as
Peter is sensible so he's not a 35 year
old man wanting revenge on a kid College
freshman little man but I'm guessing
you're missing me at Midtown High huh
he's like a perfect balance between the
ultimate and 616 version of the
character seeing this series version of
Electro made me realize something he's
probably the least developed Spider-Man
villain in terms of Personality or
motivation I may piss people off by
making this point but the fact that
every version of Electro in movies and
cartoons is so drastically different
proves to me that there really isn't
like anything interesting in the
material to adapt for him he's either
the Red Skull son or a bullying victim
that becomes a metaphor for Columbine or
a guy with a severe sci-fi medical
condition that pushes him into this
whole Hollow Man bit or a socially
awkward nerd that has severe abandonment
issues remember in web of Shadows that
whole I gotta save my sister thing even
though that was a character that was
made for that game at best in the
ultimate cartoon in the recent game plus
Spider-Man no way home a little bit they
all shared this weirdly defined goal of
becoming pure energy or something like
that but that's so vague and
uninteresting we have no concept of
something like that because it's not
real so we can't like understand why he
wants that so bad you know with every
version of Doc Ock the specifics of how
he gets his arms and his relationship to
Peter Parker different but he generally
always has the same characterization
with Electro it's always some random
nonsense that has nothing to do with the
comics because there's like nothing to
adapt nearly every every Spidey villain
has some kind of storyline that goes in
depth about them or at least a series of
issues that defines a strong
characterization for them Rhino tried to
quit crime and marry that nice lady he
met at a diner Shockers like a down on
his luck working class super villain
that's trying to make ends meet instead
of world domination Sandman is a pretty
strong moral code and sometimes serves
as an ally to Spidey and even became a
reserve member of The Avengers they
tried a bunch of [ __ ] with the lizard
that didn't work but at least they made
attempts go watch that video and thank
God this show dispenses with all that
and like makes him turn into lizard once
and only once and then that's it but
what does Electro have he's
um kind of a mutant but not really he's
bisexual I guess he was once the face of
an anti-establishment political movement
during the 2008 financial crisis
that was weird one time he almost blew
himself up by plugging his ass into a
billboard and then thanked Spidey for
saving him
maybe there's like a really good single
issue Electro story in an anthology book
that I missed but I think he like
kind of sucks actually now that I think
about it this way Electro is just there
to fill out Sinister Six rosters and
everything he's got nothing going on
but I'm getting sidetracked this one's a
bot a bot about two oh
only I didn't say fudge I said the word
the big one the Queen Mother of dirty
words
when I said this show planned ahead I
meant it there's a whole slew of
background characters from the comics
that fill out the cast with the plan
that they'd eventually become major
characters in The Forefront of the story
they throw that stuff in for the
[ __ ] like me that actually read all
the comics or at least all of them until
the concept of Kindred made them
permanently allergic to them look they
got Stan Carter before he became the sin
eater and he's voiced by Biff from Back
to the Future that voice fits him really
well actually oh come on to Wolf kid's
just saying what everyone's thinking
look Sarge when he takes the law into
his own hands he goes too far you ask me
Spidey hasn't gone far enough it's kind
of dark that his partner is Gene DeWolf
knowing how that would end up later on
foreign
let this be like a wake-up call to turn
your life around
God is great God is good and we thank
him for our food
look we got Cletus Destiny over here in
this institution for deranged criminals
he doesn't talk but you know he probably
murdered his grandma in this continuity
too there's hydroman voiced by Bill
foggerbaki when we're clear a remote
activate the countdown and cascading
detonations bring the building down in
its own footprint Roger Kingsley the guy
who is actually the Hobgoblin instead of
the seven other guys we thought it was
I've heard somewhere that this sleazy
reporter guy is actually meant to be
Matt gargan before Jonah ruined his life
we even got Miles Warren preparing for
clone Shenanigans by messing with
people's DNA they were gonna do the
clone saga and that blows my mind I know
people used to trash this show for its
really unique art style but I've learned
to love it with time the characters are
designed by comic artist Sean Galloway
in his distinctive art style with big
emotive faces and exaggerated
proportions I think considering his art
from around this time this show did a
really good job of tempering it down to
something more pretty in animation form
which they also did shortly before for
this with those two Hellboy animated
movies that shared a lot of the crew
with this series I wasn't sold on it at
first either you know when I was 10
years old and had my dad pirate this
show for me because they never actually
played it but eventually I came to an
understanding with everyone's weird
action figure elbow joints it's less
noticeable when they have sleeves on but
what the [ __ ] is going on with Harry the
art style does lend itself to animation
very well however everyone is simplified
just enough to get them in and out of
some really Dynamic poses really quickly
so you go from this oh man I've got
three science papers due Friday I have
to study all night for a big exam and
I'm still batting zero with Felicia to
this
Spidey hasn't moved like this in 2D
before or since the fight choreography
in this series is only rivaled by the
MTV Spidey if there's anything I still
can't quite reconcile with the look of
this show it's the very earthy muddy
color palette that felt like a lot of
shows from around this time everything
is brown and beige and dark green and
really dull blues and Grays that holds
back the very fun character designs I do
wish this show was more colorful at
times I like that John Jameson isn't a
werewolf in the show I love that this
Series has memorable locations that we
visit again and again the recurring set
pieces lend a really strong sense of
realism like this isn't just an
infinitely large cartoon city with a
billion skyscrapers it helps all this
feel so real from Peter's life at the
high school in the bugle to the criminal
underworld with recurring locations like
tombstones auto shop and Penthouse
Norman Osborne's Penthouse and Oscorp
and Montana's bar that eventually is
given to Russian Spike Spiegel while
Shocker's in jail oh yeah the voice cast
a bunch of [ __ ] a-listers in this
damn show
they got Revolver Ocelot to be Peter man
and for many people he's like the
definitive voice for that character John
DiMaggio's range is insane because he
voices two characters in one scene
talking to each other and I can't even
tell you got power no one else got not
even Spider-Man revenge is for Chumps I
don't care about Spider-Man all I ever
wanted was the big score every guy who
played Spider-Man in a video game for
around this time is not Spider-Man in
this show and it's pretty great Keith
David was Tombstone for one episode for
some reason I like to think that he was
still Kevin Michael Richardson at this
time but he just sounds like Keith David
over the phone like I sound like my dad
over the phone but not in person you
know I always wondered why that is but I
feel like if I ever asked Keith David at
a convention he wouldn't even remember
this show and like wouldn't have a clear
answer oh you know he did that same
thing for you Young Justice he plays
Mongol for one episode and then dips
maybe he's just really busy [ __ ]
Freddy Krueger is the vulture and season
one Meg Griffin is Gwen Stacy and I
think this show and Emma Stone are the
only reasons people under the age of 40
even like that character and of course
Steve Bloom kills it as Green Goblin who
is the main villain of the series ah but
the Green Goblin doesn't take orders
from insects the Green Goblin swats them
into Oblivion I also think Alan ratchens
is like the perfect Norman Osborne voice
and will never be topped Ever Enough you
want more than my son I can't have weak
men in my organization Otto that guy's
IMDb is funny because he's barely in
anything especially not much Voice work
he's one of those actor for higher types
that just appears in small single
episode roles and live action shows and
then randomly he's also the best Norman
Osborne voice ever uh he's also the
clock King one time fair I love this
voice cast and I always get excited when
any of them reprise their roles in other
media although Josh Keaton should have
reprized this role in another animated
series from around the same time yeah
we're talking about that mess so for
those who may not know this cartoon was
intended to be part of a shared Animated
Universe much like the now beloved dcau
or the 90s Marvel animated Universe this
universe was helmed by Christopher Yost
and unlike the others listed all of the
shows in this one were on completely
different networks with Avengers Earth's
Mightiest Heroes over here on Disney XD
and Wolverine and the X-Men on
Nickelodeon and spectacular Spidey being
all over the [ __ ] place I could never
keep track and that's why I had my dad
pirate it the CW under Kids WB which was
immediately consumed by four kids and
then transferred to Disney XD once the
merge happened the connections in this
universe are thinner but they're there
like Wolverine in the X-Men cartoon
bumping into the hole and then
mentioning the animated film where they
first met or Thor in the enchantress
carrying over their beef from the double
feature into the Avengers show in all
three things Hulk and Bruce Banner have
the same voice actors and generally the
same design which is kind of nuts
because it means that Nola North
Deadpool is technically the one Canon to
The Spectacular Spider-Man universe or
at least you know that was the intention
but Disney bought Marvel and the TV
rights to Spider-Man not the movie
rights mind you and that's still tenuous
to this day but they had all of spidey's
TV Adventures on lockdown and some
pencil Pusher decided it would be easier
to drop this show and start fresh with
something more under Disney's management
and control rather than delegate with
the crew that was already working on
this thus the planned crossover episode
where spectacular Spidey would have met
the Avengers was redubbed at the last
minute with Drake Bell to lead into the
Ultimate Spider-Man cartoon this was
done so last minute that they forgot to
swap one of the lines and you can still
hear Josh Keaton's Voice come out in one
scene
is this safe no it's not all of this
making the Earth's Mightiest Heroes
Spidey a strange Schrodinger Spider-Man
that is neither ultimate nor spectacular
but some Twisted form that lies in
between I'm Spider-Man
what's wrong with your voice
[Music]
I have a feeling a lot more of this with
spectacular Spidey influenced earlier on
Darren Norris doesn't Voice Jonah
instead they got JK Simmons to prepare
for his return as Jameson in the
ultimate show but Darren Norris is
definitely in this episode we check
security cameras it was pushed over by
an angry mob I bet he got recast too and
with Betty Brandt they didn't even try
to recast her so she's still Greg
Griffin he doesn't have that spider
signal on the ultimate show but you know
where he does use it this episode is
kind of a weird epilogue to spectacular
in a backdoor pilot to Ultimate because
Peter mentions he's 17 years old uh I'm
17. respect your elders punch his design
changes could be attributed to age but
the bagliness of him seems like another
way to visually prepare the audience for
the new show on the horizon I'll tell
you that the Avengers crossovers being
Canon to spectacular is a lot more
likely than ultimate because Luke Cage
and Iron Fist completely desync it by
not being teenagers otherwise there's
nothing in these Avengers episode that
says it can't be spectacular Spider-Man
if you care about that [ __ ] whatever
Canon is a cruel and fickle mistress
that doesn't love you much like
Spider-Man 94 this show was the point of
inspiration for a lot of the creative
choices in the movies that followed it I
suspect because lazy ass screenwriters
would rather get Cliff Notes from a few
episodes of a cartoon than actually read
a bunch of comics the guys who made the
cartoon did the research for you so we
got scientist Gwen Stacy Max Dillon's
Powers coming from electric eels Oz
court building Rhino suit Montana being
shocker and homecoming vulture trying to
get revenge on a rich guy that wronged
him when he was just a scientist Ned
leads his redesign as an Asian-American
blindfolded Spidey beating Mysterio by
just not looking at all of his Holograms
and Mysterio working with tinkerer and
chameleon Etc I did say almost perfect
so I need to find things to complain
about because everyone thinks I'm the
angry negative guy I guess even though
the majority of my videos are about
thing things I like in the last three
years
uh what are some things that aren't
awesome about this show sometimes the
music choices feel really dated like
stock music from the time and uh other
times it seems like the composer just
gave up and reused some of his work from
Batman Beyond hit the alarm
making Walter Hardy Uncle Ben's killer
was dumb he's supposed to be like a
master Thief but he robbed the fight
promoter in broad daylight with a
witness around and no mask on then he
jacked a car while leaving a gunshot
victim that's not stealthy that's not
classy I know the idea was to create
some your dad killed my dad drama
between Spidey and black cat because
that was preferable to her scrometing on
his balls because he's underage or
whatever but I don't Vibe with it
hey Spidey never does anything easy
never has to be Spider-Man I've never
asked for these powers
[Music]
but which one is real my father's
struggling there's no place
a guy who can't even see one of his
friends are trying to help
ugly neighborhood
you just took the jackpot accept the
gift the partner rejected
just once I'd like to be early for
school put me down
Innocent but still at Large
[Music]
so what if nobody threw a parade
Spidey stays because Spidey is needed
Maybe
something to hide
something to protect hey if I wanted all
the glory I wouldn't wear a mask
[Music]
if you're subscribed to this channel
you've seen every episode of this
multiple times so there's no point at
all in convincing you to watch it or
recommending it so I'll just say I'm
glad I re-watched it and I plan to do so
every few years instead of failing to
Grapple the cold hard reality that this
will never get a third season learn to
let go kids you see I'm trying to
reverse jinx it because if I play the
pessimist and say that this will never
come back the chances that it might
increase so that everyone can come back
to this video at some point and comment
and say that it aged poorly I'm an agent
of chaos I don't have some profound
conclusion to make on this show that
hasn't been said a million times before
already it's a show made by people who
really love the character cast is great
the animation is really cool
uh it sucks that it didn't get some
detective the more seasons clearly it
had an insane amount of untapped
potential but even what little of the
show that we did get was incredibly high
quality stuff and I think we have to
keep appreciating it for what it did do
in addition to wondering what it didn't
get to do who knows if it'll ever come
back but I'm happy with what we got I
probably do ultimate sometime soon and
next if you want but you gotta keep
fueling the space truck these videos are
getting expensive to make because I keep
making RoboCop costumes and flying
guests to the studio which is just my
house so we can be on a blue screen like
the real movies you can support the
channel by joining my patreon that's
only a dollar or buy some of my old toys
and junk on eBay or you can buy some of
the merch or you can just use my
fortnite Creator code because you
probably play fortnite or you can just
make sure to hit that Bell icon assuming
that actually does something still I
don't know at this point see you next
time Goobers
foreign
[Music]
[Music]